are you hoping to find love I have love
are you just not sure if it's the love
that's part of it I'm just kind of
curious too would there be a break in
this relationship is is that right is
this the second break that you've had
yes yeah so anyhow that's a sign for you
I think at the moment technically if
we're technical we're single I'm
technically single okay got it we were
together for basically three years yeah
we broke up sometime in the middle we
got back together and then he moved to
Seattle a month ago okay and we were
doing long distance and then we broke up
Friday but like we're still in love and
we just know the long distance doesn't
work you're gonna have to make a
decision as to who's going to go where
either you're going to have to go live
there or he's going to have to come back
here